and we are alive welcome everybody to
another YouTube hang out I am here with
Jennifer price the hashtag fantasy
copywriter for another fantasy strategy
session welcome back thank you it's good
to be here Jenna's rocking the shirt
yeah I totally believe believe mission
rock the limited edition shirt I love it
we're matching I got the hoodie of it
we're matching um so this series is
about jen jen is a copywriter she she's
built the business rubber one word of
fantasy and we do a monthly call to talk
about where she's at in her business
talk about progress and help her get to
the next step so Jen how we doing what's
the latest give us the update I'm doing
fantastic lots of stuff has been
happening which is awesome I have been
to big things have been going on one is
I've been working on my website which
has been great and in process of doing
that I've been sort of refining kind of
my um you know my package offerings to
people and kind of like how I get leads
and then you know how I get clients and
upsell them from there um so one of the
things that we talked about in our tgim
group that I think I brought up at one
point time was whenever I talk to
clients I work with them I create a
document for them that I've always
called copy foundations and I've come up
with a new name for that which right now
I'm temporarily calling it a thousand
threads so um but anyway uh that
particular product is it's adopted I
crave them that has everything that I
need to write from has like a kind of
their brand essentials so it has you
know they're um you know there are you
know what's the return on investment
what's the benefits versus features you
know I really described or customer
avatar it has all these really key
things that they can use to create all
of their marketing messages so and I
find that I do a much better job writing
for them when I do this and in the past
I've just sort of give it to them after
the fact like after they signed up you
know to have me write something for them
they're like well this is amazing and I
realized if that is really something
that you know is valuable on its own and
some people and the price of
never i quoted somebody always come
include that in there because i had to
do the work for that first so um to me
it made sense to kind of use that as a
way to not only help them understand why
I price things the way that I do but
also some of them I just want to pay for
that by itself and then once they see
that I think they'll realize the value
of working with me and so if I could
charge that a really reasonable price
then you know it'll be much more likely
to work with me on other projects and so
that's kind of what I decided to do and
I've already started this lot last month
sampling doing that with a couple of
clients who have signed up with me which
is awesome so it's really been effective
and I I'm so excited about that it's
worth you know I click on the right
track there so I love it so how much you
charging for that first process so that
first process i'm charging 299 and um
and it's just a really great way because
in the past what people would do is if
they want me to write just one page for
them exam for example and it was just
like an about page on their website you
know i would say you know it's a minimum
of 500 bucks because i'm thinking of
myself I've had to create this fantasy
document for them and do all this
research because I'd want to work goes
into that and then the one page on top
of it they just don't understand one
page like that's all that's really
expensive um and so instead now they're
seeing that I'm they're getting this you
know document plus done right then doing
the page for them so it makes a lot more
easy than for understand why i'm pricin
days away i am i love it so that's now
going to be your entry point of
everything no matter what the scale is
of the project afterwards do you have to
understand the climb before you can do
the work exactly yeah exactly another
starts with them first it really starts
with their brain and what their mission
is and you know what they're all about
and then from there then I then I go and
see okay who's the perfect match for
them who's a perfect customer for them
rather than saying ok let's go but your
research and see you know who's a good
client for you it doesn't work like that
it's really starts with them and their
brand and then it goes out to see who's
a perfect match for them and what
they're all about you know whether it's
their one word or their mission or
whatever it is right and then from there
um you know then you know then I
basically analyze that for them I kind
of summarize it for them and I'm not
analyze doubling I'm a lousy person but
it's really more about you
really understand who the customer is
really understands or fantasies are
right and so I put that all down for
them and it makes it so much easier of
them to you know to see exactly what it
is the value that I give them for the
for the people who you've just signed up
how many you got two or three new people
how many sounds good do for sure but
three three and one more in the hopper
yeah what kind of what kind of work like
who are the without senior named
whatever it's fine but what what kind of
people are these that you're now working
with yeah they're all different so one
of them is a brand new nutritionist and
she really wants to UM just have a one
landing page like a home landing page
wants someone to write and design a
whole website for her but she doesn't
have money right because she's brand new
like brand spankin new so um so her that
made her understand like all I had a
second stop in the end than a one page
and so it all made the pricing really
made sense to her the other person i'm
writing for is a fitness um a conference
and so they are um basically trying to
get people to come to the conference and
they have a chance to speak in front of
a different conference so much of their
target customers will be in the audience
and so they are asking me to write a
presentation script um kind of like a
sales scripts similar to something that
I might do I do I've done video scripts
in the past though it's a similar kind
of concept um it's like a five minute
you know this is what we're about you
know please come to our conference that
kind of thing so again same thing the
Foundation's document was really
essential for me to be able to write a
good script for them even though just
making that longer at the script itself
and isn't who they were guaranteed yep
those the two they're guaranteed and
then the third person that I'm that's in
the hopper is a someone who wants me to
write a website for pages of the website
for her and her websites not very long
it's not very copy intensive but I still
need to you know again understand
exactly who her customer her perfect
customer is and so I did that way I bid
it out is a copy foundations document
first and then four more pages on top of
that got him and how did those two three
people find you what was the Mo's a path
there um they all
male me through um kind of referrals so
actually um let's see here so the first
person nutritionist family through a
networking group um that I had gone to
and also she had known me through one of
the workshops I did and then the second
person actually wasn't attendee at my
workshop and she had actually come to my
workshop for a different purpose but
then has this side gig with the fitness
industry and so thought of me for her
presentation and then the third person
was a referral from the first gal who
come to my workshop I had um written a
page for her she loved my page so much
that she's been referring me to lots of
people actually spin great and then she
um recommended me to his other writer
who referred me to this this other
website gal so so far it's funny because
I know we talked last me about my
workshops right and I was sort of like
reevaluating those workshops and I was
thinking okay maybe I should rethink
them and so I decided take a break for
the month when work on these other
things um but clearly those all kind of
have you know now kind of got me some
leads from referrals and whatnot yeah so
I'm looking back the notes from last
month and it was about the workshops as
being the strategy trying to do more
work says with connectors and trying to
find local business coaches in the area
to be able to do workshops with you yes
I started in definitely not so the funny
thing is I was laughing after I got off
the call with you because I was thinking
about the people that I know that our
business coaches and um and there's
quite a few of them in my networking
groups so there's a quite a few coaches
there that a lot of the clients actually
come from networking groups but i
thought you know it's still wouldn't
hurt to talk to them so i started
investigating conversations with them to
kind of you'll get a feeling for them if
that's something that will be valuable
for them and then i also from there i
also decided to look at other because i
think one of things that you really made
me think about was ok what kind of other
groups are out there that might have
more of my target market in them um and
so I started talking to a couple people
through that I know that our web
developers and just ask them do they
know of any club groups that have like
online entrepreneurs or people who are
more likely to meet something because
they're online
I did get a couple of really great leads
on some meetup groups that have um that
are basically made up of people who are
kind of more online I have to have more
of their products online so I'm really
excited to to check out those meetup
groups to it because they might have
some key people that I can offer the
service taste similar to what you were
suggesting with the business coaches so
what happened with the bit so the
business coach it you talk to mm-hmm
what was the feedback what happen with
them um she felt that it wouldn't
necessarily be um so I talked so I have
a meeting with another one next week but
the one that I talked to so far has said
that she she didn't feel like it would
be any different audience than what i'm
offering through my networking because a
lot of our networkers are the same so
you know maybe we just wasn't the right
person to chat with about it but she saw
the value in it and she actually came to
one of my workshops so I think maybe you
know then she actually you know so I
think she knows she's definitely does
the value and I think she sees it might
be great but I don't think she
necessarily thinks like her advice to me
was like I don't think you should be
offering this free re offering so cheap
and your network would be the same as
mine so you know you know maybe wasn't
the right person to talk to about it hmm
and it's more thinking about her clients
right to were potential clients because
she could use I mean even if it's
somebody in your network than me they
may I mean ideally you're going to
different networks to but having
somebody within your network now come
and listen to you and here we have to
offer they may have known you as the
copywriter but now seeing what you can
offer and walk it through a process
makes it more interesting urgent someone
have to do business with you know it's
lots of my network but I don't
necessarily hustle to go and find them
business all the time we're the ones who
are on top who are on top of mine who
are giving me value if I went to
somebody presentation and I got I found
it really helpful interesting then I'd
be much more likely to tell somebody
about it the next day or for the next
month it's in my head so I don't know
that I would necessarily give up on that
but uh yeah i agree i haven't get it i
would be looking cool is she I'm just a
brand new coach is she's just getting
started in the business no
she's I think part of it is she's kind
of changing her focus to do more and
maybe I you know that's actually now
that I'm thinking about it talking to
she's got attention to her focus a
little bit to do more masterminds um and
so she wants to help lead mastermind
groups but some of those people that
she's leaving the mastermind group are
completely different and not in my
network so maybe there would be a good
opportunities me to offer to go to her
mastermind groups and um do a free
workshop with them because they are
totally different she has a nice kind of
with the people in the self-help
industry she's basically trying to get
other people that are in that her
similar industry to kind of do a best
friend group with her that might be a
really great a great great place to go
yeah I mean this is one person but I've
been looking at I would I would even be
looking at doing cold introductions like
it's great to start with the people that
you know and if you know a couple
business coaches great you have a
meeting lined up next week it's awesome
I'll be trying to say how can I do at
least one workshop a week with somebody
yeah because it will improve your
presentation skills and you get some
feedback immediately but it's also been
what's been driving you know the
business and the referrals for you so
how can I increase that so I'm getting
one a week it'll mean you know you have
to be having five to ten you know yeah
pointment coffees meetings with people
and a business coaches somebody who's I
guess you're talking about a partnership
you're offering you know free value for
them it's it's not it's not you calling
up on a sales con saying hey buy my
stuff right it's I want to provide value
to your clients in this free thing it's
a lot easier to get a coffee meeting set
up to talk of what they're doing and
learn you know you can also offer value
in that session of you can look at how
they branded themselves and we have some
ideas on words that their use it as an
example so they see the value what
you're doing but I would or maybe a
better question is how come you haven't
reached out to business coaches that you
don't know yet um i just thought i would
reach out with people that I knew first
um yeah that was kind of it and i also
thought to myself oh maybe i should look
at what my workshop in
general I was thinking instead of
writing a workshop doing a worship about
how to write your sales page or how to
write your about page maybe I do a
workshop that really would lead in well
to my new introductory product um you
know which is you know the copy
foundations if I can create and it's
kind of focused around that and I can
convince them then maybe two hired me
for that then it would lead to more
business overall um but I also had I
also mean I have set up next week is
with a gal who's she's not really a
business coach she's more of a um she
helps people with she's sort of been
doing is helping people get like
convincing him to get in social media
and get online in video it's kind of her
thing but to her next her next big
project she wants to start working on is
how to teach people how to create their
own online course and obviously I think
that's a perfect match for me because
you know if she's creating online course
it's gonna be a little online courses
then they were eventually gonna need you
know a page to get people to buy it from
so um you know I think being strategic
about exactly i'm talking to is good
idea to UM then reached out maybe more
to kill people like that but I agree I
mean I I don't think it would hurt to
reach out to people i don't know it's
cuz you're right i'm already aren't
enough people my networks right so I
like that idea yeah and so they do
second with influencers and business
coaches are one kind of influencer but
anybody who's selling to other
businesses is a potential fit and just
having your name out there and be on top
of mine you might be probably the only
copy writer that that is actively doing
this and that's how you build a
service-based business I guess you will
reach a point where it becomes a tipping
point where you just have referrals
coming in and you don't need to do any
marketing right the marketing is the
work the market is the experience that
you create rights if you do an amazing
job for these two people they're going
to remember you they're going to come
back and buy more from you when somebody
ask them hey do you know a copywriter
you're going to be the person that they
referring because you've given them a
great experience so the marketing is the
work the marketing is the experience
that you give them but you don't have
enough of that yet to bring in a lot and
so the marketing now is going out and
making the connections
and given any experience through the the
workshops and through that first initial
product you can lodge em so the I just
want to be doing is like I would be
sending out five to ten emails a day to
people you know spend an hour every day
looking up people in the area someone
local who whether they're you know even
potential counts or lawyers or other
people were selling to to businesses
uh-huh you uh offer them right this
lawyers I think that's a really
brilliant idea because I think Laura's
are always looking for ways to to talk
to their customers too so it's another
excuse for them to yeah it could be it
really depends on the person mm-hmm um
some people really take pride in
offering value to their clients and some
people just do the job the people who
are in service-based businesses though
tend to understand the servicing side
yeah it's so a lawyer you know if you
want to get a shareholders agreement you
can go to a thousand different lawyers
to do it why am I gonna pick John over
Jill well maybe John cares about me more
curious about my business more and they
had to go through the same thing with
your building their business up
networking talking to people running
seminars to the point where then they
don't these do anymore because
everything just comes in oh that's the
that's the friendly lawyer that you know
you got to talk to really help you out I
wouldn't necessarily put all of my eggs
into one basket though just just test
like test business coaches test lawyers
test accountants test other consultants
test web developers you know test
anybody who's selling to business and
seeing if there's a potential that
there's update like you reaching out to
10 lawyers and nobody's writing back and
it's just not an interest but the
business coaches are you know really
shining through or mastermind groups or
meetup groups or whatever it is then you
know the focus a little bit easier to
get along but
that's really the start of a service
basement business Wow until you get
enough clients that you're doing the
work and that the work just is awesome
and people just keep coming back yeah I
like the thing with the so anyway so
that that's like I would it may be
uncomfortable ah but i would start least
trying in some areas and you can you can
prime your network to say hey I'm
looking for lawyers I'm looking for
accountants of liver consultants looking
for what developers do you know anybody
they can set up a meeting yeah but also
just tweeting somebody who's is local
and said hey I'd love to meet to see how
we might bill to help each other
businesses grow yeah that's right yeah
its social media a little bit to you
because those people who are on social
me apprised savvy with being online
because again I think that's part of the
problem is a lot of uh along the
networking groups that I've come across
and even business coaches or coaching
people who are have you have direct
marketing businesses like in a
multi-level you know um you know Mary
Kay or can be closed or things like that
and they just they just have absolutely
no need for a copywriter so um you know
they have me did you don't budget right
they ever need they have a hardcore need
but they probably don't realize it and
they can't afford it uh okay so I think
making some kind of plan there could be
helpful in terms of reaching out and
trying to make more of those connections
honestly if you if you just ten times
the number of people that you are having
meetings with yeah that's it like in a
couple months your business gonna be
full yeah I mean well and like I said
like I was surprised to all the people
like I mean I took a break from work
shop just this one month I thought I'll
just take one month off and all these
referrals came in like all at once from
my past workshop so you're right I like
I think I'm just ratita can just keep
doing them i think i will continue to
get um you know more referrals and get
full schedule which is great yeah i mean
the tricky part is just getting enough
for those workshops in having the
conversations to make it happen yeah um
talk quickly about this client that's
doing the sales conference this came
from a friend who was
looking with the sales conference right
it's um a gal who came to my workshop
she has her own business locally but she
used to have a fitness business and so
she is involved with two other partners
in um sort of it's it's a it's a
leadership group where they help
businesses learn they help fitness
businesses learn how to run their
business so they give them educational
um you know materials on like you know
the basic business stuff like how to get
new clients how to run your business how
to basically higher standards because I
think a lot of people get into the
fitness business because they're they
love you know they love the fitness
business they don't you know they might
have gotten their degree in movement or
whatever but they have no idea how to
run business and so um the idea is to
help those professionals do better job
running a business so they also have a
conference that they do once a year and
and so they want to increase attendance
at that conference and so they're going
to a different conference where they're
our sponsor and they're gonna be able to
speak to that that group so one of the
things I love doing when I'm working
with a bigger potential client right
like the natural holistic person I you
know they have budgetary can restrict
shins are just starting out they may use
you again but their business has to grow
or they can do one thing every couple
months or whatever it's good to have and
I'm sure you'd like her in her business
it's it's hard to build up get to where
you need off of the backs of you know
peer startups who don't have a ton of
money Rob work where there's more of a
company and they're organizing
conferences and have you know have many
people in there uh what's very common is
you get one small thing to work on right
so your work on script for one video as
part of this big annual conference I
love spreading a seed and then letting
it letting it plant and trying to branch
out into other areas of that business
yeah so just as an example was on a call
just before this it was on a call with
Bank of America okay uh I don't how much
I should say actually I should have said
the company and I think our America I'll
live in America because the guy they're
like wall is the founder bank of america
AP Giannini is my favorite entrepreneur
yes favorite that's cool yeah and so
like it started off with one simple
thing right like we want to work with
you on creating content for our small
business community yeah this is online
community our budget is this we want a
one article every two weeks that is 500
words around and that's our budget and
what do you think ah so first me it's
always understanding the metrics like
what what do you hope to get out of it
and for them it's views they want tons
of views on it and then I always start
okay that's totally doable we can do
that I love AP Giannini there's a
connection there but I always now try to
add more right so listen I love you too
bye love making videos how about we do
something youtube on there are we
limited to 500 words how about we write
more they'll do want to increase the
frequency I love AP Giannini as an
entrepreneur I'd love to maybe do
something on his story and share some of
the wisdom because I don't believe
people know about who this guy is this
amazing entrepreneur and the lessons you
can learn from him right in so you know
the guy I'm talking to is eyes wide open
tons of opportunities so quite often a
client comes with one specific thing but
they will end up needing way way way
more and so what else might this client
need and can you sprinkle a little idea
on them so you're right in one video
script like what is their website look
like it's promoting this sales
conference what are their newsletters
that they're using in their campaigns to
promote it what are they putting up on
social media to get the word out what
happens after the conference are they
following up with people or they have
sales and email sales letters like
there's so much copy that's involved in
this way beyond just this one little
thing yeah and if you can get your eyes
on it till least see like whatever their
landing pages now I'm sure it could be
better right you add add some gin magic
to it it could be better
and so even following up and looking at
say hey I also noticed like your landing
page you know the title could be way
better it could be it you know this
isn't great because of these reasons and
I would do something more like this and
then down the page is a whole bunch of
other things that might need to be fixed
um not just complaining let's just say
like here's all the things that are
wrong but often it like a little taste
the sailing out if you tweaked it like
this a little bit and this arista
they'll just take a copy paste and never
pay you and run off but it's just a
little sample of what you could
potentially do on that page I would look
I would like to see you making money
yeah I totally love it idea uh you're
right because I think there is a lot of
potential here because they do their
landing page right now it's basically um
the 1i have up actually is from last
year and she said there they sought to
develop the one from this year so they
could potentially need help there I know
for sure she wants to create some kind
of a you know like a free giveaway or
something on their website to compel
people to kind of look at the conference
from last year going away maybe video
from last year or something to convince
them to sign up for this year and so
they I know there's a lot of potential
work out there so um I love that idea of
giving just them some ideas based on you
know even their landing page from last I
could say hey this is a couple things
you could do for your landing page for
this year to give them a taste of you
know what I can do for them yeah I like
I would love to see you making ten times
more with this current client right even
and I mean it start with having an
understanding of the business you're not
picking a solution that they don't need
other using social to promote it or not
like no point pitching a Twitter
campaign if they have nothing on Twitter
you know you don't convince them of
something new better to improve what
they're already doing yeah so asking
them how do you promote this likes okay
so there's a landing page do you guys
send emails out are they being open like
isn't working on the emails and and just
saying you know what I'd love to just
take a look at it just you shoot me the
link to an email that you're sending or
or landing page you're designing I love
to just take a look and just just see
what you guys are up to and maybe I have
some some feedback for you
um and then and then see right like you
get it in if you can see that you can
make a big impact there with with what
you're doing with the goal of being
anytime they're doing anything copy
related they pass it through you for you
to get to write it or for you to just
give your your feedback on it for how it
could be better because a lot of times
when people hire somebody is for one
specific thing mm-hmm this is what we
need but really they have a much deeper
need and it's up to us as entrepreneurs
to uncover it so we can get that that
business not just hope that because we
did a good job on it they're going to
give us more you can uncover it faster
right by just having a conversation yeah
and just prompting that even mean to
make I think that's when things I think
I think you add a couple couple sessions
back you you know really installed my
brain was like when you're having a
conversation with somebody about a
current project like to just pepper in
like little hints about like potential
work I could be doing for someone else
cuz that's something i didn't use to do
it i'm getting much better I um just
talked about potential future stuff and
not say hey you know this is early i
think you should hire me for this but
like you know sprinklin possibilities of
ways they could hire me or like you said
ask really good questions so that i can
provide value for them cool new feature
builder is asking in the live chat does
Gentry any templates to gift to
potential clients I do yes I do i have
um i have a template on my preview right
now on my website on how to write an
about page there's five different ways
to write you know there's a million ways
you could write an about page but i have
five different suggestions of ways to
write them and they're basically five
different templates is what they are um
and then when I um when I do a workshop
i also have those those templates for
you know cuz i have a workshop on how to
write in about page so i obviously
provide those templates there but i also
have a workshop that I did on how to
write a sales page and i have a
different template for that and so when
i'm talking to potential clients I
sometimes will just send that to them or
if I'm just talking to an entre
in a networking group or you know like
in our TGIM group some was right in
sales page and I offered to send them
that template if it's helpful for them I
have a basic sales page template to so
yeah so you can sign up on my website it
was it's you so much calm but we've
linked it up in the description below so
you guys can can check that out too Jen
we're at i'm already is crazy how
quickly it goes most most most important
thing you do for the next month is what
i am gonna reach out to potential
business coaches or other people who can
i can maybe like lawyers accountants
that kind of thing what could
potentially offer value for doing a free
workshop for their clients and then just
schedule you know at least one workshop
workshop of not that hopefully maybe two
three maybe once a week even um today on
web got time foreign and all that so a
little exciting cool well good luck
thank you everybody for watching if you
have tips or feedback or advice or
questions for Jen you can leave it in
the comments below afterwards have an
amazing rest of the week continue to
believe fantasy whatever ender one word
is like your fantasy red downright your
words down words make it real I love it
I think again I appreciate your advice